Okay, and the correct answer is, as you may have
suspected, all of these. There are many different factors in each
website, is a little bit different. And, you know, different website
may have different needs. some, some websites you know, video websites,
like YouTube or Justin TV. Bandwidth was a major factor
because video takes a lot of bandwidth. And you have to
figure out, you know, how you can support that much bandwidth.
You know, you're sending a lot of data over the wire,
over the Internet. Machines, computers very often CPU's a limiting factor. if,
if your website does a lot of computation you know, you may need
a lot computers to handle all of the traffic, to do computation
for everybody. Or maybe you're running out of memory. You know, you're storing
a lot of data or you're caching a lot of data in
memory. You may need to store that data across many computers to, to
make it work. Power, you know, if you're adding a lots of
computers, power is actually something you
need to start thinking about. You know,
I've visited Google once and it was cool that had a,
a map on the wall of where the big power plants
in the world were. They are building data centers in near
power plants so they could always have powers. And storage, of course,
is similar to memory. You know, memory, disk space, or technologies
that fall in, in between. You know if, if you're storing a
lot of data. You know many websites store a lot of
data. If users are submitting content to you, photos and status updates,
and, you know, comments and that sort of thing. That
starts to become a big factor in, in your decision making,
and how do you store all of that data. Facebook
has so many photos, they have to. They've unbelievable amount of
disk space required to, to manage all that information and
you know Google has basically the entire internet indexed and you
know that they have to store, they basically Google's [INAUDIBLE] entire
internet across all their machines so they can do searches quickly.
So all of these are things you need
to scale and of course there are other, other
things as well but I just want you
to keep in mind that every website is different.
Every website has different needs and different limiting,
limiting factors whether it's machines or bandwidth or power.
Anything can be the, the, the culprit when it
comes to keeping your website online, stable and fast.